- On this episode,
we talk guide life and
a very, very special
guest visits us.
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this episode 199 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Before we get into the show
Staphon I couldn't, yes turn off
the sound on your snaps over
there, Staphon I could not help
but notice that you are
wearing the Kobe jersey.
Last night was an impressive.
Did you see that Brett?
- I don't watch
sports but Ralph did.
- Ralph? Impressive last night?
- Well, I mean you give a
guy 100 shots he's going--
- 50, 50. Anyway,
super impressive.
Good job Kobe.
Amazing, amazing career.
Episode 199 super
excited about that India.
Super excited because we have
another guest I will let him
explain himself in a second
however India something very
amazing is happening right now.
- Amazing.
- Like all-time amazing.
- All-time.
- Your mom is here.
- Mom, roll over here.
- Yes, get in here.
Mom, tell the Vayner
Nation who you are.
- I'm India's mom.
(India and Gary laughing)
- That's the best.
I'm so glad you're here.
How long are you staying?
For the weekend?
- Just for about five days.
- Awesome. Enjoy.
Fun to have mom here, huh?
- Where are you from?
- India, your face begin the
same color as mom sweater.
- I know, so exciting.
- Alright, my man.
- Alright.
- Tell the Vayner Nation who you
are a little bit about this and
then we will get into the show.
I'm actually
excited about this one.
I think most of the shows
that I've been having guests and
we've been doing a lot
of guests, very thematic.
I think this one is fun for me
because I've enjoyed jamming
with you through the years
and I feel like this is just two
business dudes going to
go through the questions.
But first I'll let you do your
little spiel, give them some
context and then
will get into the show.
- My name is Brad Grossman and I
have a company called ZEITGUIDE
and we produce a
book every year,
zetiguide.com, and it's
digital too and
we update it every week
with a newsletter.
it's a ZEITGUIDE meaning
the guide to zeitgeist.
Zeitgeist meaning spirit of the
time in German and because of
this great thing that you're
doing for us by being on your
show were giving all of your
audience members a 50% discount
so if they go into the coupon
code and they put #AskGaryVee--
- Do they have to
put the hashtag?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Staphon, make sure
you link that up.
- #AskGaryVee you
get 50% discount--
- How much is it?
- For the book it's $100 so
now it's $50 because it takes
700 articles distilled in here
and you're in it actually.
Remember?
- I do, I do.
- Your quote--
- It's the best
page of your book.
page of the book.
Let's get to it right now.
I'll show you.
Basically you say the future
of advertising or to succeed in
advertising is that you have
to reverse engineer, right?
- Sound like
something I would say.
- Reverse engineering attention.
Rather than retrofit predigital
advertising techniques ZEITGUIDE
friend and serial entrepreneur
Gary Vaynerchuk says that
marketers have to
reverse engineer attention.
- It's true.
- So there you go.
- Cool.
- And our company is basically
to help leaders like yourself
and everybody in the world to
stay on top of trends that are
changing and transforming
businesses so they're best
prepared for the future.
- As you can imagine a lot of
the up-and-coming entrepreneurs
what you have is time and
so you can actually go,
now are you smart enough
to digest all that information
into the important points?
That's up to your skills
or not but you have
time for the people--
- Why you guys have real jobs.
- Right. Exactly.
For you what you're selling
especially to the top premium
executive who she or he is just
running their business and not
in digital, not in zeitgeist
for me for a lot of people that
watch it our life is predicated
on this moment. There's a lot of
people who are Fortune 500,
Fortune 5,000 CMO's who they're
in biotech and they haven't
thought about how the zeitgeist
impacts their business.
Guess what if the gal that owned
the most taxi medallions in the
world had been reading the
zeitgeist, forget about the
guide which we prefer, reading
the Zeitgeist as a slang term,--
- Listening to the world.
- maybe she would have been
the person that invented Uber.
It's about understanding...
By the way I never knew where
the word Zeitgeist came from so
thank you for that nugget.
- Spirit of the times.
- It's been a word that always,
it runs in my mind quite a bit
because it is the
thing that matters.
To me I call it the market.
I call it the second industrial
revolution, the thing that is
happening right now that so
few people understand is that
technology is going
to disrupt all of you.
So bookstore owners and
taxicab and black car owners
they already know this.
The people that don't
know this are teachers.
Who because Khan Academy and
Udemy hasn't fully gotten there
yet but in 12 to 15 years there's
going to be a stunning amount
people that have their children
learning in that environment.
Construction workers
'cause robots may do it.
UPS and FedEx because
drones or Uber will do it.
Everybody. All of us.
Everything is
going to be disrupted.
- Even entrepreneurs
though as well, right?
- 100%. Especially entrepreneurs.
Wine Library's, every winery
in America should be delivering
their product
direct to consumer.
All of them.
Wine Library should
be out of business. 100%.
- So Neil Rosenthal.
- He's a supplier and a retailer
but no I mean, not Neil,
I mean the wines
that Neil represents.
Every individual winery, the
producer should go direct to
consumer. They don't because
they can't sell as well as Neil.
They don't because they don't
have operational infrastructure
to create enough demand and
then deploy the volume
of product they make.
Just to teach you about the wine
world, a winery makes a bottle of
wine that you buy for 20 bucks
and they're selling that to the
wholesaler for 8 to 10.
They're not making 20
but if they sold it to you
they could make 20.
There's a lot of money
in it if you know
how to disrupt yourself.
The problem is most don't.
- Right.
- And the zeitgeist--
- It's hard though to
sell direct to consumer.
- It's extremely hard.
- [India] The first question is
do you think brands should
sell direct to consumer.
- Get out of here.
- [India] No, I'm serious.
- I think you guys know this
show well enough to know that
was just very
zeitgeist-y in itself.
Is that right?
- [India] Yes! From Ben.
- You like read,
you anticipated--
- Well I researched the guest
and then I chose questions
based on that.
- [Brad] Look at that!
You're the
zeitgeist of the zeitgeist.
- Somebody's working.
Mom, somebody's
working around here.
- Great.
- Good job India we're
really proud of you.
Alright, first question.
- [Voiceover] Ben asks,
"Do you think big brands should
"sell direct consumer?"
- Yeah. Yeah. Well, I think yes.
I think Amazon is going to be a
player where they're basically
selling directly to consumer--
- AKA with their private labels
or when they're selling
Pepsi through Amazon?
- I think they're going to use
Amazon as a mechanism to sell
direct to consumers but the
question is will eventually
people like I want Pepsi I want
to Pepsi.com or Pepsi's Facebook
page and just get
directly from there.
But that's not really direct
to consumer because it's going
through Facebook so I think
you still need to use these
platforms to go direct consumer.
- Got it.
I would say that Amazon is far
less direct to consumer than
Facebook because Amazon's
actually a full-pledged retailer
and very honestly I think a
scary one for these guys and
gals that are running these
businesses because
Amazon's got real data.
In the CPG world, retail and
brands the scariest thing is
when a retailer is
gets too much leverage.
The biggest brands in the world
are paying for placement in
Walmarts and Albertson's and
Costco's and Safeway's
that are very expensive.
This is not the way
was 30 or 40 years ago.
The retailers didn't have
leverage, the brands did.
- Yep.
- And so that got expensive.
Direct to consumer is inevitable
the problem is the following big
brands like Dove or Pepsi can't
go direct to consumer because
Costco and Walmart and Tesco are
going to say what are you doing?
You're not cutting us out.
The second those companies show
a move to wanting to go direct to
consumer the big retailers are
going to drop their product from
end caps to the bottom shelf
or kick them out of the store.
Which then would affect them in
a 90 day period because their
sales would collapse which
then would make the stock price
collapse so they're
basically caught in
what's called channel conflict.
They can't do it.
So what's gonna happen?
Here's what's going to happen.
India and her mom are going to
invent the best peanut butter
you've ever tasted and they're
going to start going direct to
consumer and they're going to
sell on Instagram and Snapchat
and Facebook and quietly but
surely because that's where the
attention is all of a sudden
their business is going to do
$40 million not four
or 1.4 or 400,000.
- Yep.
- And then, what's a
big peanut these days?
Peter Pan peanut butter?
- [Margo] Laura Scudder's?
- What's that?
- [Margo] Laura Scudder's.
- [Gary] Laura Scudder's?
- Smuckers maybe.
- [Gary] Smuckers right.
- Jiffy.
- [Gary] Jiffy, Jiffy,
there we go.
Go ahead.
- Well I like grinding
the peanuts in Whole Foods.
- Let's use a soda as an analogy
then Coke and Pepsi are going to
be like wait a minute
what's this new craft soda?
That's doing real volume and
then they're going to be stuck
because they are going to
get squeezed from both sides.
They're going to get
squeezed from the up-and-coming
entrepreneurs that actually now
have scale and use things like
Uber and Postmates or whatever
for distribution and use social
media and this for awareness and
they're going to get pressured
from the retailers for
then not to do the same.
Pepsi can't make Pepsi Gold
the direct to consumer at scale.
They can do a little one
off, a little holiday thing.
Tough.
- Starbucks is an interesting
example because I just went to
Seattle and I just saw their
new kind of innovative space.
- Okay.
- It seems like what brands can
do is develop or create a new
product that people don't
actually know is part of the
brand and sell it direct to
consumer and see
they kind of have the backup.
- No, no, no.
100% they can do that.
Here's the problem, it doesn't
matter what the consumer knows,
the retailer.
See the thing is most people
don't get is the number one
competitor to the biggest
brands in the world
are their retail partners.
- Mhmmm. Mhmmm.
- So they can't again at the
highest levels on a board at
Walmart they'll say look
what Coke just did today.
They created Scmoke or Chugabuga
- And they're selling it.
- And they're selling it and if
it gets big that's a problem for
us because it's going to build
the cadence and the ability and
the data to remarket to
those people and
they're going to cut us out.
- What do you think about
the future of the store?
Do you right now all the brands,
even Birchbox I know or
Warby Parker, who are
disruptors, right, are like
they all want stores.
It's actually the best marketing
mechanism in the world.
Do you think these retail stores
are going to be the place where
conversion rates are
going to happen the most?
- No, I think if you look at
e-comm it chips away every year.
11 percent of the market,
13 percent of the market,
16 percent of the market.
E-comm will continue to
grow especially with this.
Especially with our
impatience, I want it right now.
- And through
social channels too.
- And whatever, right and were
not even factoring in it's going
to take 20 years for what I'm
talking and by then VR will be
there so are we literally living
in a virtual world and shopping
in a virtual store and it's
actually being physically
delivered within an hour?
There'll always be disruption
but here's what I will say
they're not going away.
Stores are not going away.
Stores, they're not going away.
Do I think they're
emerging better than ever?
No. Just because Birchbox
and Warby Parker
have stores right now.
Let's talk about another thing
when the shit hits the fan and
I mean the collapse of the
valuations of these super
companies and these unicorns
that are rhinoceroses and
I don't think Birchbox is.
- What's a rhinoceros?
I know unicorn is a billion.
- Yeah a rhinoceros is what
these things actually are.
They're actually rhinoceroses.
You like it?
- Yeah. Like it a lot.
- Anyway nonetheless I think
that too many people who
watch this, too many people in
our zeitgeist-y kind of love we
think things are binary that
e-commerce is coming and
there will be no stores.
I mean I made these
mistakes as a kid.
There is no absolutes.
- There's no absolutes.
- Right?
- You gotta do everything
it seems like today, right?
- I would say you've
got arbitrage everything.
If you can get a store location that
you don't pay too much rent on,
that does great branding
and awareness and
your selling stuff, Mazel Tov.
If you can figure out a
Instagram campaign that,
you have to be agnostic.
- Right.
- You have no emotion
to where it happens,
you just want it to happen.
- Well, how do you
afford all that though?
- You don't. You don't.
Which is why--
- I would rather have Ralph
actually do the real jobs than
having him just work on social.
- I get it. I get it.
- It's allocation of resources.
- That's exactly right.
- I'd rather have
Ralph do everything.
He's very capable.
- Yeah, he's the best.
- Show Ralph, Staphon, come on.
Let's wake up here, Staphon.
You saw what Kobe did.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
I think that that's why
strategy is so interesting.
That's why love to do
what I do for a living.
- And you have to
keep reinventing.
Now you're all about Snapchat.
- I'm only about attention.
Snapchat just
happens to have it.
- Yeah. Are you loving it?
- Love it.
- [Voiceover] Matt asks,
"The average amount of
"email someone gets
is 147 per day.
"The average pieces
of mail four per day.
"Is it time to get
back in the mailbox?"
- Yes.
- You think so?
- Absolutely.
- Talk about it.
- Absolutely because that's
why I actually created a book.
- Yeah.
- Because it's
actually tangible product.
It doesn't evaporate
in the digital ether
so direct mail even though
I think it is customary--
- Hold on go back to
your digital ether
evaporation statement there.
If I got this in a PDF, forget
about that because that's just
supply and demand economics this
is about if you want something
or if you don't want
something a.k.a.--
- That's true, that's good.
Yep, yep, yep.
If you really want it
you're going to find it.
- Correct.
If I want the ZEITGUIDE I'm
going to want it one way and the
other the other thing is I think
that's about getting to the
point of knowing about the
ZEITGUIDE but once you know it
to me it's the electronic aspect
is so great because is on me.
I'm not carrying this
fucking thing around.
You carry it around.
- I fit in my back pocket.
- I do have a book
on me at all times.
- You should have this next
to you on your night table
while you're sleeping.
I have your book next
to me on my night table.
- The greatest thing that could
ever happen to you every single
person on Earth has the
ZEITGUIDE app on
the home screen of their phone.
- Yes.
- It would be the
greatest moment of your life.
- And we keep updating and
keep updating, yep, yep, yep.
Let's do it, Ralph.
- Ralph. What was a question?
- [India] The question was
the average amount of email.
- Email costs zero, fuckin'
mail costs a shitload of money.
What's his name? Matt.
- They actually just
reduced the price of the stamp.
- Defense. Matt, Matt
wake the fuck up.
The answer is sure but you
gotta run the economics.
If it costs zero but you have
creative costs somebody's gotta
write the email,
those kinds of things.
Mailchimp might have a,
you know, the cost benefit
analysis is devastating.
Go run 10,000 pieces of
mail that oh by the way
cost you $13,000. $13,000.
- By the way, this is the reason
why this is so expensive and in
addition to the intellectual
property the reason why this is
so expensive because it cost
like 100 bucks to
print each one.
- Get the fuck out of here.
Your cost is not--
- I do on demand printing.
- The only reason I'm not
throwing you out of this room
and making fun of you for $100
pamphlet is because I know how
good the IP is an information
is good and it's why you're even
allowed to sit here
because $100 book is ludicrous.
- Well now it's $50.
(laughing)
- Be careful I'm about the
negotiate you for 75% discount.
Ralph, there's
going to be new code.
- All right, done do it, Ralph.
I want it to be the same price
as his book which is
$18.99 or $17.99.
- That's right, $17.99.
Want to do that? Done.
82% discount
or whatever $82 off.
Done, nice work.
That was good, I'm excited.
India. I like negotiating.
Staphon do not put up this
episode until the code works
for 18 bucks.
- $17.99.
- $17.99
You can use that for a stamp.
- It's true.
So anyway, Matt, I think
it's all about the end result.
If $13,000 to send 10,000 pieces
of mail and one of four I don't
know who one and four, first of
all that's scary to me and I'll
tell you why, it means that
80% of Americans are getting one
piece of mail and it's probably
the 80% of Americans that are
not going to convert to a sale
as easily as the Americans at
the top 20% that are getting
20,000 pieces of God damn mail
because their data shows
that they have the
income to buy things.
We have to start
grounding things in real life.
I think the reason I am so
excited lately is everybody,
all these businesses are
about to go out of business.
I'm so--
- We're talking
startups or legacy or both?
- There's so much bad
that's about the happen.
- Yeah, I know.
- And in business land and
especially in startup land and
the truth is it's going to make
me feel really good and
I'll tell you why.
All those same friends and
acquaintances and pundits said
I wasn't smart for building
an agency during
the boom of startup.
- Right.
- And I ate that.
You have to understand--
- Why did they say that?
Why did they say that?
- Because agencies
are stupid businesses.
- Yeah but you have
a different agency.
- Fine but do you understand?
Why? That's why.
You also know, you've been
around, you know for your own
business but you also have a
feel on me, I was sitting at the
top of the pyramid.
I could've raised a
$200 million fund.
I could've gotten $50 million
for any god damn idea
I had to build a business.
Do you know what would have
happened if I said I've got a
tech idea for the wine business.
I would've gotten $50 million
in funding in four seconds.
- So why didn't you do it?
- Because I knew I wanted
to build practicality not
create high risk.
Because all this spiel I push on
you guys on Snapchat, this show,
the DailyVee, I live it.
I live the hard work.
I live the practicality.
- And it's fun.
- And I live below the
headlines in the trenches.
140 emails, four pieces of mail
that's a nice little data set,
what happens when
you start digging?
What happens when
we talked about the
actual costs involved?
What happens when I educated you
that that average was predicated
on the people that won't convert
to the sale and that...
And so that's it, it's layers.
I'll be there in
a minute, Tyler.
India, lets go.
- [Voiceover] Michael asked,
"Do you see bots becoming big
"in the next 24 months?
"Microsoft and Facebook
are heavily investing.
"Will bots become a
tier 1 inbound channel?"
- Well, they just talked about
yesterday these chat bots on
Facebook M messenger.
I know Ralph and I were
just talking about this.
- Bots will probably make,
when will you close content on
'17 ZEITGUIDE?
- September.
- Bots will make an
appearance in your next one.
- Absolutely. Absolutely.
- Hundred percent.
- We talked about bots
in terms of ruining
the advertising agency--
- Oh that's
different programmatic.
Yeah, yeah. These are
utilitarian bots.
This is going to work.
WeChat and other
platforms have proven this
so I'm actually excited.
Truth is I'm actually
excited to deeply dig
into it this weekend.
I have a flight to San Diego?
- [India] Yeah.
- I'm going to read quite a bit
on that flight on just bots
'cause it's that important.
- You don't need to
read, just give me a call.
- But you know this about me,
the reason I get to be quoted in
your books is because
I like doing the work.
- Totally, you don't
want the Cliff Notes.
- I don't want to read it.
I want to be the
content side of it.
- Totally. There you go.
I think it's going to be really
big in customer experience.
It's going to be big
in customer experience.
- It's going to be huge.
Guys, the AI.
- Do you want to talk to a bot?
- I want to talk to whoever--
- Right. Even credit card
companies like press one isn't
that kind of like a bot?
We value time over
human interaction.
It's just the truth.
We value time--
- Not in everything though.
We're having fun right now--
- In sex I think we value
the human interaction--
- But aren't we
having fun right now?
- Yes, of course but what
I'm saying is we value time.
- Yes, yes, yeah.
- We value time.
This is fun because were doing,
I'm talking about the following,
I do not want to talk
to an operator. I don't.
If it's more efficient
this way, that's the thing.
What I think is going to happen
is were going to get really,
really, really into AI, bot
culture when things can be done
for us, we will take advantage
of that every day of the week.
- Yep, okay.
When you think
it's going to happen?
- I think really feel
real stuff next year.
I feel like next year there
will be an execution in a bot
environment that
everybody's doing.
Kind of like a FitBit.
- Slack.
- It's a Slack, yeah it'll
probably happen in Slack by the
way from a business standpoint
but think FitBit, think Evernote
think when texting popped.
There's going to be something
that everybody will be doing in
bot form on Facebook that
people are talking about.
Which is like--
- Is Siri a bot or
the Echo a bot?
- Yeah. That gets into AI.
That gets into different
stuff of that nature but yes.
The truth is I don't want to
start pontificating here because
I want to get grounded in my own
thoughts on this so I don't want
to fully answer that question.
I don't know how the experts
are dissecting it plus I want to
taste it more but here's what I
will tell you every TV network
in the world should start
creating a bot on Facebook that
helps you DVR at scale
no matter where you are.
If I'm having coffee with
India's mom and she's like you
gotta watch
"Billions" (taps phone).
Like there's
things there's thing.
There's things.
- By the way, that's what
Comcast could do
to save themselves, right?
The cable companies?
- [India] Max.
- Max.
- [Voiceover] Max says,
"Kobe scored 60 in
"his last Lakers game!
"What we learn about
business from Kobe?
"Thoughts on his legacy?"
- I don't do
sports but ask Ralph.
- Ralph, what do we think we
can learn from what Kobe did?
Take 100 shots?
- He actually covers
the sports for me.
- Go ahead.
- [Brad] I was a bad sports player.
- You miss all the shots you
don't take and if you ever get
accused of a terrible crime
buy your wife a big ring--
- [Gary] Oh geez, he
hates Kobe. Kobe hater.
He's a Celtics fan?
Oh. Got it.
Makes sense.
You're a Patriots fan?
- I am.
- Jesus Christ.
- [Brad] He's from Boston.
- I respect that.
How old are you?
Perfect, no respect for any
Boston fan under the age of 34.
You had it too
good, you're soft.
Alright listen,--
- Isn't your client
GE moving to Boston?
- Yes, they are.
Here's we can learn about
Kobe, Kobe is very smart from a
branding standpoint
in a lot of ways.
He knows that the jokes of even
the most cynical of he took 50
shots last night which I think
has only happened four times in
NBA history so it's pretty
intense he knows that something
that I know which is that part
gets forgotten in seven years.
What you'll hear is what is
what's repeated 70,000 times
which is that Kobe
scored 60 in his last game.
I think some of the people
that run the best brands and
businesses in the world don't
sweat the short term narrative
because they're smart enough
to play the chess moves to
understand when that wears off.
As a matter of fact a lot of
politicians do that because they
know that we say that
negative ads are bad.
We Americans, we
hate negative ads.
Negative ads are bad.
It's the only
thing we respond to.
And so I will run negative
ads 'til your face falls off.
I will take the heat for 48
hours of like I'm running too
many negative ads on Brad.
I'll win the election
and nobody will remember.
And so I think that's we can
learn from Kobe last night.
I wanted to make it valuable, I
think I did a nice tie-in there.
What Kobe's actions were on the
court last night is he knows the
narrative that best positions
his legacy and so he was going
to take as many shots as he
had to to maximize that headline
'cause it was going to be the
only thing left and a lot of you
right now worry way too much
first of all what everybody else
thinks secondarily worry too
much about the narrative is in
the short term you know like
starting an agency seven years
ago at the height of your
ability in the tech sector when
the tech sector is exploding
because you wanted to play a
practical long game not what
people were whispering behind
your back for a 12 month period.
- Can identify with
you for a second?
Yes, I am identifying with Gary.
You just saw my mentors and
the guy that actually started my
business with
which is Brian Grazer.
- Yes.
- Yes. He loves you, by the way.
- Me too.
- So does Ron.
I had this job before this
and I left in 2008 as
his cultural attaché.
His private ZEITGUIDE.
And I build that into a business
where I could work with other
leaders and when I left in 2008
to start this business people
were like the fuck
are you talking about?
What the economy is about to
crash, which they were right, and
you're basically thought of
as a luxury because I was just
helping some Hollywood producer
come up with movie ideas.
- Yes.
- But I kinda knew that the
world was going to change and
I would be able to come more of
his necessity because everybody
was going to be so crazed by
knowing what they need to know.
Yeah, it's taken me 2008
it's taken me eight years.
- It takes time.
- Right. It takes, well that--
- Building something
real takes time.
- It really does if it's
authentic and you don't
want to pollute your brand.
- That's right.
Mom raising a great
child takes time.
- It does.
- India was the
disaster for many years.
- Was she?
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- Not that I remember.
- But it takes time.
Trying to connect the points for
other I'm living it now with my
two children building
anything great takes time.
- [Brad] Patience--
- Is the game.
It's the game.
Question of the day.
Our guests get to ask it.
You can ask them
anything you want.
It's a good data research thing.
You'll get hundreds of comments
on both Facebook and YouTube so
be strategic or if you're just
curious about something or you
want to ask is anybody
really to teach me about sports.
I don't know what
you want to do.
Any question you want.
- I guess the question is as
all these innovations that are
happenings or disruptions and
obviously you know what Gary's
advising everybody if you had
to think of the perfect job that
you would want to have in the
near future and in the long term
what do you think it should be
or what would it be for you?
- I love it.
Kind of like how
you thought about it?
- Yes, exactly,
exactly, exactly.
If you're in college do you have
college audience members right?
- Junior high too.
- And junior high, right--
- And 73-year-old.
- Who do you want to
be when you grow up?
- Still at 73 you can do another
20 years of working their dream
thing even if they've
not done it for 53 years.
- Exactly, exactly.
When I was in high school
because I was watching "LA Law"
and "ER" I wanted to be
a lawyer and a doctor.
Now I would never want to be and
I would be the worst in both but
(laughter)
I actually was interned at
Mt. Sinai Hospital
one year and I threw up
on a patient that
and I knew that wasn't for me.
- You saw the blood?
- It's the smell.
- Yeah, I hate the smell.
I hate it. I hate it.
- It's the smell.
In the early 90s, I wanted to be
a doctor and now I know being a
doctor is if you love doing then
it's great but it's really hard
to do so what do you guys want
to be now and what do you think
you'll have to be or
want to be in the future?
- Love it brother,
Thanks for being on the show.
Congrats. Continued success
with this. $17.99.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(upbeat hip hop music)